well i mean i came here
in 90s i did braveheart and mel said you
just come to california meet some people
so
so he liked you he took you under his
wing in a way i was only supposed to be
on braveheart for two weeks this
bridegroom didn't have a [ __ ] name
the bridegroom
and i was supposed to get killed and
because you're everywhere in that movie
yeah he then mel said no no we're
keeping him
so i was four weeks in scotland and i
thought then they were moving to ireland
for five months so i'm like so what the
[ __ ] i've got up to a production see so
what am i doing here i was only supposed
to be for two weeks now it's four now
you guys are going to ireland i'm
curious am i going with you hold on a
second i checked the script he's
flipping through the script to get to
scene 200 and something
oh no you're here tommy oh okay great
six months
six months i was on that movie
six months was it one of the best
moments you're like the best it was the
greatest well what about it was so great
hey it was your first movie my first
movie and it was it won six oscars
and
i mean come on you knew it was an epic
i'm sitting on the battlefield with uh
mel gibson's brother donald
without the d
donald
i'd so he tells that story he told his
name was donald without the d and the
girl said oh arnold
no donal without that never mind
but i'm sitting on this hell with donal
without the d
and uh
he i'm just certainly going to watch
these battle scenes i mean there was no
seat it was very very little cgi back
then and it's just thousands of extras
it's the irish army the irish volunteer
army
i want to kill people oh i'm going to
kill you all right
and just charging each other to the
point where mel was like you know what
guys it's a [ __ ] movie we don't want
anyone to die so
but just watching it was just this epic
thing he just knew it was going to be
huge but it's got to be tough going from
one of the best movies ever made to then
continuing your career because usually
it's like you do a shitty movie i did
this piece of [ __ ] followed by another
piece of [ __ ] followed by hey you were
good in that piece of [ __ ] yeah and then
we oh that's a good one and there's
another
but to go from you were in the
one of the best movies ever made and
then what was the next thing you did the
next thing was
the saint that was good
another good one
the game another good one well little
parts but you know it was still
something
and then
i think it was gladiator was next jesus
which is another one i was supposed to
be on
for
a short period then russell russell
tells this story then russell and ridley
had the conversation oh let's keep this
kid around why is it what is it about
you it's my fabulous talent and
[ __ ]
charisma is it people they they what do
you think mel thought when he met you
are you just i mean maybe what i see is
just a really likable fun guy to have
around who's actually tout really
talented yeah plus i think
you know
we live in such a
we work in such an insecure
[ __ ] business i mean i mean i mean my
god if you you won't become an actor
then good luck stuck with that but it's
so [ __ ] so so inviting it's so so
destroyed
humiliating the times and all these
other things yeah
but um but what is it they maybe you
think that they had a liking to you that
they felt better when you were on set
they liked having you around i don't
know really i don't know are you friends
with him to this day i am yeah i still
talk we're also i still talk with melvis
um readily i've got tons of love for
he's just you talked to ridley i was
brought to ridley in a while now i have
to say you know a long time since i
spoke to ridley but i'd love to manny
death he's he's great
[Music]
when is the last time you watched an
episode of smallville town
i mean i i don't even probably forever
what do you say we revisit well
like watch an entire episode
no i mean like watch an entire series
join tom welling and michael rosenbaum
every week as they rewind every episode
of smallville and discuss their
experiences with friends fans and
co-stars tockville the ultimate
smallville podcast
you